[Music]
Charles debuts his first official
portrait as king the photo was taken at
Buckingham Palace last week after
Charles took on the title of King
following his mother Queen Elizabeth
II's death in a touching nod to the late
Monarch a photo of the queen and her
husband Charles's father Prince Philip
appears in the background I think in the
same way that her father was
um absolutely determined that his
daughter should learn the ropes in the
shadow of his kingship so too was
Elizabeth Keane that Charles learned and
that she mentored him so that he was
prepared the photo of the late Royals
was actually a Christmas gift from the
couple to the Queen's father King George
VI in 1951. now we don't know when his
majesty inherited that image but what we
do know is what Queen Elizabeth Left
Behind for the king the queen passed on
the duchy Lancaster estate to King
Charles and that is worth anything
between 715 and up to 900 million pounds
it's a huge amount of money because
quite simply it is a massive swathe of
land and premium real estate around the
United Kingdom I would imagine that with
the King it'll be again his flunkies who
pull out the credit cards or the cash I
remember one occasion being in Malta
with Charles and Camilla on an official
engagement and I found myself in a
bizarre situation shopping in a glass
shop with Camilla and she was picking
out all these beautiful glass Christmas
trees as presents to take home so I
copied her and when he got to the till
realized that I was the one with the
money and of course she stood there
while a flunky moved in and a deal was
struck the money or whatever it was was
handed over but it was very apparent to
me there and then the Royals do not
carry cash the Royals might not always
have cash on hand but King Charles has
always been prepared to take the throne
no one could have known that he was
going to spend more than a half a
Century Learning the ropes of being King
certainly in the later years of her aim
the queen would share important
government documents of course with the
blessing of the government so that
Charles could understand the legislation
of the days that he could get involved
as we know he did because he loved
ministers over certain things but it was
very important to the queen that if he
was going to have all these years in
Waiting then he really needed a good
grasp of how things worked and she was
very generous in that respect and more
recently in her reign of course you know
the queen put down the foundations for
Charles's future the Commonwealth for
example the head of the Commonwealth is
titled that the queen passed on to
Charles before she died it was
guaranteed to go to him and this wasn't
a hereditary title so in all of those
things she was Paving the way for the
Future King Charles III Charles's
official coronation is expected to take
place next year